il prennent la terre la Bour pour faire
pour faire de la route et des pierres
pour faire pour faire la terre la Bour
qui alors où va-t-on avec tout ça ah je
sais pas on trouve que les pays trop TER
il faut le enlever un
[Musique]
peu cette Bretagne traditionnelle de
bocage monsieur nous attend dit dans le
finisterère au train où vont les choses
dans 20 ans dans 10 ans peut-être même
elle n'existera plus
dans beaucoup de communes à tel gruc
comme ailleurs les agriculteurs ont du
mal à comprendre le pourquoi de certains
grands travaux qui bouleversent la terre
bretonne al il y a une bne
et la route passe ce côté elle passera
de ce côté pass ce côté alors qu'on pit
la faire justement la redresser
simplement quoi ici a une dimination de
1 M78 par
80 alors il va falloirattre
quoi
le propriétaire du terrain prend la
dénivation et tout la moitié de la route
et pourquoi on se demande alors où vous
êtes là il va falloir qu'il cultive
alors oui il faudra cultiver les pierres
quoi paril y a rien d'autre et il faudra
charger la route autrement on ne peut
rien faire mais c'est vous qui avez
demandé cela ou pas ah non nous n'avons
pas demandé non on nous a mis de de
force quoi parce qu'il fallait qu'on
puisse venir du village vers le haut oui
il fallait il fallait une route mais on
avait pas besoin de faire tellement de
sagré pour hein alors qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire là on va tout détruire ça va
coûter très cher oh sûrement mais c'est
dans le c'est dans le REM alors nous
autres on nous dit pas le prix hein sauf
plus tard on sera ce qu'on aura payé
quoi c'est tout est-ce que vous étiez
d'accord ah non non non non nousétions
pas d'accord sûrement mais vous l'avez
dit quand même non oh oui mais ça ne
sert à rien de parler chez nous alors
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on il fasse
et alors dans la terre qui est à côté là
on va bon ils prennent la terre les Bour
pour faire pour faire de la route et des
pierres pour faire pour faire la terre
la Bour quoi alors où va-t-on avec tout
ça ah je sais
pas on trouve que les pays trop TER il
faut leur enlever un
peu quand vous parlez de péril du
terroir on vous répond
remembrement au niveau de la réalité
quotidienne tout semble se limiter à une
petite querelle à propos de vieux
talu madame Batan on est en train ever
tal partout on est obligéonstruire
ailleurs on fera plus on laissera ça
comme ça qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse et vous croyez que c'est mauvais
pour l'agriculture c'est très mauvais
pour l'agriculture premièrement pour les
bêtes on a moins de lait quand il y a du
vent c'est un pays d'élevage ici oui
c'est un pays d'élevage on a beaucoup
moins de lait ah oui quand surtoutici ça
souffle quand il y a la
tempête les cypr ont été mis ici
pourquoi les cyprin ont été mis pour
abriter les toitures du vent qui vient
de la mer
oui des kilomètres de talu brise vent
sont déjà tombés sous la dent des
buldoer et un jeune agriculteur affirme
que ce n'est pas
fini cet alu il doit disparaître parce
que le géomètre a établi son plan de
telle façon de telle sorte que le
propriétaire soit obligé de la raser la
propriété est en petite pour récupérer
ces 3 m qui sont au-delà de ce mur il
devra abattre cet alu cet alu là va
disparaître également cet alu on une
très grande importance surtout dans une
région d'élevage très venté où la
moindre perturbation à l'antique devient
pour nous une tempête est-ce que vous
croyez que c'est vraiment un saccage de
la terre bretonne oui on aurait pu faire
ça d'une autre façon en tenant compte du
bon sens et
cultivateurs alors on plante ici des des
cyprets également en Bretagne puisqu'il
y a plus de talu mais ces cyprets est-ce
qu'ils peuvent pousser CCI près ne
peuvent pousser parce que ils sont
brûlés par l'air marin le vent circule
en rat du sol les fches les brûles alors
il faut les abriter derrière des pierres
oui c'est le seul qui me reste de d'ici
près que j'ai planté autour des
bâtiments j'en ai planté là sur le talu
derrière les machines agricoles là-bas
derrière les machines agricoles et elles
ont toutes été crié et en fin de compte
ici la PL sur les 2395 hectares MBR on a
rasé 350 kilomè de talu sur les 370 quoi
alors vous voyez un peu les dégâts c'est
presque la totalité pratiquement la
totalité et il y a une solution à tout
ça oui c'est que le remembrement se
fasse que les lois du remembrement
d'abord soi modifié parce que nous
sommes sur le régime des loi de
1941 nous sommes comme sous l'occupation
allemande o le remement se fait de façon
autoritaire les cultivateurs sont
minoritaires dans dans les commissions
communales et ils n'ont pratiquement
rien à dire à la commission
départementale et vous avez énormément
de gens qui s'occupent de remembrement
et qui ne et qui n'y ont aucun intérêt
donc ça se fait si vous voulez genre de
maquignonage marché au
[Musique]
puce le bocage traditionnel est devenu
la
[Musique]
bosse expert agricole et membre de
l'Association de défense du terroir
breton Monsieur Robert gouachet craint
tout de ce nouveau
paysage je pense que les Chambres
d'agriculture vont prendre prendre le
problème en main et vont enfin informer
les agriculteurs parce que j'estime que
il est certain que la destruction des
des talu et des brises vent n'a pas
seulement été fait dans le cadre d'un
remembrement ou de travaux Connex un
remembrement il a été fait beaucoup plus
souvent sous le l'égite de l'article 836
du code rural qui permet à un locataire
de détruire uneide mais ce n'est pas une
raison les si les cultivateurs avaient
été informés des préjudices qu'il
subiraient en détruisant
C alu il l'aurait pas
fait ceux qui n'ont pas informé sont
donc à mon sens responsables et c'est ce
que le terroir breton cherche
actuellement à faire c'est d'informer on
nous a traité de poète de rêveur mais
nous ne rêvons pas nous voyons la
réalité il s'agit pas ni d'être
pessimiste ni d'être optimiste à la mode
des moutons de panug il s'agit de
regarder la terre et de voir tout ce
qu'on y fait toutes les
destructions
il est un fait certain que du jour où on
arrace tout on détruit tout on détruit
également le la vie elle-même hein il
faut il faut pas oublier que dès que
vous avez des brises vend arraché je ne
vais pas vous faire un cours sur le
problème mais toutes les terres ça sèche
or actuellement il y a une diminution
terrible des nappes fréatiques qui
baissent il y a en plus c'est parce
qu'on parle on parle souvent de
déforestation mais il ne faut pas
oublier que une forêt n'est pas
seulement un bloc d'arbre c'est
aussi dans notre pays avant tout une
forêt linéaire qui ét constitué par ces
alus par ces aorm et autres essences du
jour où on les détruit il y a une
évapore transpiration qui est terrible
et qui diminue forcément la quantité et
la qualité
[Musique]
des des cultures la Bretagne a peut-être
une vocation touristique qui va de plus
en plus marquer il est certain que pour
l'agric
et notamment en dans le Finistère les
gites ruraux sont un complément de
revenu or les gides ruraux sont
recherchés par les les gens des grandes
cités pour leur environnement Sion
détruit toute cette verdure tous ces
arbres autour que voulez-vous que les
gens de la ville viennent chercher dans
une
[Musique]
step c'est bien le terroir breton tout
entier qui est en cause c'est-à-dire
l'homme son environnement et sa culture
pour remplacer cette route empierée par
une nouvelle à quelques centaines de
mètres de là il sera nécessaire de
détruire ce petit bois qui fait partie
du site classé de la chapelle saintcum
sur la commune de saint-nique et qui
pourtant est protégé par arrêtés
[Musique]
préfectoraux la BR mon Agne c'est aussi
200000 hectares de forêt dans C
départements dont 18000 de forêt
domanial comme celle de camor dans le
morbillant SI à côté on veut faire la
bosse ici on veut faire les vauges en
remplaçant les feuillus par des résineux
il faudra alors refaire la Bretagne
quelque part ailleurs dit Monsieur
Pierre jarnaau maire de camor mais il
ajoute qu'il préférait tout de même la
conservver là où elle
est en ce qui concerne la forêt de camor
plus précisément
elle a une superficie de 630
hactares il était prévu et ceci depuis
très longtemps que sur les 630 hectares
on allait abattre environ 200 hactares
l'abattage était prévu de 1956 à
1986 ce qui aurait fait en gros une
dizaine d'hectares par an mon Dieu nous
sommes conscients qu'il faut abattre une
forêtfin qu'il faut l'exploiter donc il
faut abattre du bois seulement au lieu
d'abattre he par an ils ont atindu 70 et
71 ils ont abattu 110 hectares alors que
vous avez des coupes qui sont encore qui
ne sont pas encore ni nettoyés ni
replantés qui ont été abattu en
56 personnellement je ne trouve pas les
mots qu'il me
faudrait pour dire ce que je pense pour
pour vous dire de la façon dont je suis
émuu est scandalisé à scandalisé
absolument scandalisé d'avir qui s'est
passé et la raison de tout cela les
raisons les raisons je je ne les connais
pas exactement mais enfin il paraît et
c'est possible que en matière de
rendement le résineux serait plus
rentable que le
fillu toutefois si ça pouvait être vrai
je crois
que la préservation de la nature vaut
bien un sacrifice financier mais je
crois qu'il y a un autre problème et
j'ai la nette impression que les
ingénieurs
qui donnent des instruction et qui
assurent l'exploitation de ces forêts
sont intéressés non seulement sur le
bois qu'ils vont abattre mais sur ceux
qui vont ensuite replanter et c'est
peut-être là le nœud du problème
intéressé ça veut dire financièrement
intéressé financièrement et légalement
d'ailleurs d'après une loi qui date du
premier empire et qui est toujours en
vigueur et qui sa qui qui leur paye des
subventions alors en ce qui concerne
l'ONF je ne sais pas exactement puisque
la direction l' NF ne dépend pas de ma
commune mais en ce qui concerne le géné
rural personnellement j'ai déjà vu à
signer des mandats pour les ingénieurs
du G les ingénieurs du géné rural pour
les travaux qu'ils ont fait dans le
cadre de ma commune les travaux de REM
BR par exemple qui ont déjà un salaire
en tant que fonctionnaire de l' on déjà
je pense un salaire en tant que
fonctionnaire alors je pense qu'il y a
là un
problème qui serait intéressant àb Batt
dans le cadre de l'assemblée nationale
vous êtes breton vous ah je suis breton
essentiellement oui et alors de voir ce
saccage un peu ce massacre de la
Bretagne B ça me fait mal au cœur j'en
ai pleuré plusieurs fois et je suis
sincère
solution ma solution je ne peux pas la
trouver ça dépend pas de moi mais je
pense quand même que le ministère de
l'agriculture en l'occurrence monsieur
cointa Davar donné des instructions à à
son directeur d'arine dire monsieur
jacicio pour qu'il cesse ce massacre ce
que j'ai appelé le massacre de la forêt
de camor dans la lettre que j'ai écrite
à Monsieur Poujade le 19 janvier dernier
avant que je ne sois mère de camor
[Musique]
d'ailleurs